In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion from A4, on which we commemorate St. Monica, the mother
of St. Augustine of Hippo.
The model of a Christian wife and mother St. Monica was born into a devout family in Roman
North Africa.
Married to a benevolent but hot tempered pagan, she succeeded by her patience and gentleness
in winning him for God at the end of his life.
Remaining a widow, she did not wish to contract a second marriage but rather to consecrate
herself to a life of piety unto the education of her son Augustine.
She noted the airing ways of the young man, who fell into the deception of the mannequin
heresy, with patience, tears and prayers.
When she learned of it, she mourned the death of his soul even more, as though he had ceased
to exist, but God consoled her in a dream and assured her of her son's future conversion.
She asked a bishop well-versed in the Holy Scriptures to convince Augustine by rational arguments,
but the bishop preferred to let the tormented young man find the truth himself, and replied
to Monica,
leave me alone and go home.
It's impossible that the son of so many tears should be lost.
Augustine, however, went from bad to worse, and having decided to leave Carthage for Rome,
the capital of all vice, he succeeded in deceiving his mother who wanted to follow him and embarked
without her.
When he began his career as a rhetorician in Milan, Monica joined him and welcomed the
news of his conversion under the influence of St. Ambrose in a transport of joy.
When he was finally baptized at Easter in 387, the sorrowful tears of his devout mother were
transformed into tears of joy.
Some time later, when Augustine and his mother were in Austria on the way back to Africa,
and we're talking together about the promises of eternal life, she said to him, my son,
nothing remains to bind me to the earth.
What more have I to do and why should I stay here?
The only reason I desired to see my life prolonged a little was to see you, an orthodox Christian,
before I died.
God has more than responded to my prayer.
For I see you now despise the pleasures of this world in order to vow yourself to his service.
Why am I still here?
Five days later, she caught a fever and took to her bed.
With her two sons at her bedside, she showed herself a stranger to the things of the earth
and said to them that it mattered little where the place of her tomb should be, whether
in her own country or in Italy, for God knew well the place from which he would raise her
at the end of time.
She asked them only to remember her when celebrating the divine liturgy.
She fell asleep some days later in her 56th year.
For the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.